the realm
do you know what the realm is
[Music]
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire video
in this video i will explain what
happened when jon snow was stabbed by
his own men
in the book for those of you that don't
know this is one of those moments that
is very different from how it was done
in the show
john's final chapter might have the same
ending as it did in the show
but almost everything else surrounding
this event was different
i think you'll really like this video if
you haven't read the books already
now in game of thrones we see jon snow
get murdered by his own men
shortly after he rescues the wildlings
from hardhome but this still hasn't
happened in the book
in john's final chapter he thinks about
how he can save all the wildlings at
heart home but he never gets to go on
that mission
before i can explain what happens in
this chapter i need to let you know what
characters are still involved in jon's
storyline because a lot of them were
already dead in the show
before jon was killed when all of this
happens in the books
stannis his wife celise and their
daughter shireen
are all still alive stannis is on his
way to fight ramsay at winterfell
while his wife and daughter wait for him
back at castle black
in fact this chapter actually begins
once
elise says let them die referring to all
the wildlings at hardhome
as always jon wants to save them but as
you can imagine
there isn't much love for the wildlings
of castle black
salish tries to get jon to understand
he's making a mistake
but he says i must do as i think best
with respect your grace the wall is mine
and so is this decision
celice agrees this is john's decision
but she says
he will answer for this when stannis
comes back not only will he answer for
this but he will answer for some of the
other choices he has made as well
john believes he's making the right
choice but he's upsetting
almost everyone else around him jon snow
bent his knee
bowed his head and left halfway down the
steps
john hears a voice say his name it's the
lady melisandre who says
we must speak one of the very first
things melisandre says is
where is your direwolf i find this
interesting because i think this is some
other foreshadowing for what will
eventually happen
at the end of the chapter not only do i
think this is foreshadowing from the
author
but i also think it further indicates
melisandre knowing what will happen to
jon
in one of jon's other chapters in this
book melisandre basically tells him
exactly what will happen
it's actually one of my favorite lines
from the book i might add
what she said to jon was it is not the
foes who curse you to your face that you
must fear
but those who smile when you're looking
and sharpen their knives when you turn
your back
you would do well to keep your wolf
close by your side
ice i see and daggers in the dark
blood frozen and hard and naked steel
it was very cold this is why melisandre
says
where is ghost when her and john speak
in his final chapter
she wants to make sure ghost is at his
side because she knows something bad is
about to happen
jon has ghosts locked away because he
doesn't want him scaring shireen
or hurting any of the other animals at
castle black
melisandre also tells jon not to go save
the wildlings at harthome
she says solis has the right of this
lord snow let them die
you cannot save them no one will make it
out of this mission alive
i have seen that in my flames jon
doesn't believe her though
he says your fires have been known to
lie jon even references what melisandre
said to him earlier in this book
once she told him to watch out for the
daggers in the dark
it seems to me that you make nothing but
mistakes my lady
melisandre says all your questions shall
be answered
look to the skies lord snow and when you
have your answers
send to me winter is almost upon us now
and i am your only hope john thinks
having hope and melisandre
is foolish he leaves her standing there
not knowing just how right she is
he worries about how he will save all
the wildlings at heart home
he wonders if his men as well as
torments will be enough
now he's not necessarily worried about
getting there as much as he's worried
about getting everyone safely back to
castle black
on their way back they will be slowed
down by thousands of free folk
many of them sick and starving jon
thinks about the letter that spoke of
dead things in the woods
and dead things in the water this is
when jon starts spreading the word
he wants all the leading men to meet him
later this evening
so they can discuss their best way to
save everyone at heart home
then we get some more foreshadowing when
jon finds out ghost is acting very
different
something has jon's direwolf lashing out
at some of the other members of the
night's watch
jon discovers this for himself when he
sees that ghost will not sit down
he won't even listen to jon when he
gives him the command to sit
jon even notices more months old raven
is agitated as well
snow the bird kept screaming snow snow
snow
it's almost as if these animals are
trying to let jon know
something bad is about to happen
afterwards
jon once again tries to get some advice
from his brothers in the night's watch
jon is still figuring out how he can
save all the wildlings that are stuck at
heart home
but his brothers offer him no advice
whatsoever
they feel the same way as celise and
even melisandre
they think jon should let them die the
more wildlings that die
the fewer they'll have to feed a castle
black if the wildlings at heart home
need saving then let the wildlings that
are already at castle black go save them
jon realizes his brothers won't be of
any help so he ends the conversation
again
now what jon snow has done immediately
after this may be some foreshadowing as
well
jon has some of his men dig out the snow
from the ice cells at the wall
the snow was falling heavily outside and
the wind from the south was blowing the
snow right up against the wall
as well as the doors that led to the ice
cells the reason why this is so
interesting is because this is where
jon's dead body will most likely be kept
most fans believe
as jon is dying he will leave his own
body and
enter his direwolves while he's inside
of ghost
someone will set jon's lifeless body
inside one of these ice cells keeping it
on ice
until he's able to go back into his own
body i think it does make the most sense
when you consider
everything is set up in the chapter
right before jon is stabbed
right after this is done is when tormund
giant's bane arrives back at castle
black
jon finally has a chance to discuss the
rescue mission with someone who will go
with him
however as soon as they sit down
everything changes
this is when jon receives a letter
bastard was the only word that was
written on the scroll
no lord snow or jon snow or even lord
commander
simply bastard and the letter was sealed
with a smear of hard wax
jon cracked the seal opened the letter
and read
it says your false king is dead bastard
he and all his hosts were smashed in
seven days of battle
i have his magic sword tell his red
[ __ ]
your false king's friends are dead their
heads upon the walls of winterfell
come see them bastard your false king
lied
and so did you you told the world you
burned the king beyond the wall
instead you sent him to winterfell to
steal my bride for me
i will have my bride back if you want
mance raider back
come and get him i have him in a cage
for all the north to see
the cage is cold but i have made him a
warm cloak from the skins of the six
[ __ ] who came with him to winterfell
i want my bride back i want the false
king's queen
i want his daughter and his red witch i
want his wildling princess
i want his little prince and the
wildling babe and i want my reek
send them to me bastard and i will not
trouble you or your black crows
keep them from me and i will cut out
your bastard's heart and eat it it was
signed
ramsay bolton true born lord of
winterfell
alright now let me explain what this
letter means when this letter says
your false king is dead it's referring
to stannis baratheon
whoever wrote this letter wants jon to
believe stannis is already dead
but that isn't the case as i said at the
beginning of the video
stannis hasn't fought ramsay yet but
since jon isn't there
he has no idea what's happening then the
letter says
jon and stannis lied about mance
raider's death
now you see in the books mance raider
wasn't burned alive like he was in the
show
melisandre actually burned someone else
and mance is now
glamoured or disguised as another man
now instead of burning mance raider
john and melisandre send him to
winterfell instead
in hopes of saving jon's sister arya in
the books
ramsay doesn't actually marry sansa he
marries a fake arya stark instead
so this would give the boltons a better
claim to winterfell
but jon doesn't know she's fake he
thinks ramsay really had arya
that's why he sent mance raider there to
get her and that's why this letter says
give me my bride back the only thing is
the fake arya hasn't arrived at castle
black yet
that's why jon still doesn't know if
it's really arya
now there are a lot of fans who believe
the letter was written by someone else
john knows whoever did write this letter
knows a good bit of information because
only a few characters know that mance
went on this mission
so either ramsey really did write this
letter
and now he has mance held hostage at
winterfell or this letter could have
been written by stannis
or maybe even mance himself but i don't
want to get into all of that
in this video after jon reads the letter
he thinks about what it says
it makes him think about some of his
fond memories at winterfell
as well as his brothers and sisters now
john decides
he no longer wants to go to hart home
now he wants to go to winterfell
after discussing the letter for a while
jon heads for the shield hall
where all the men were gathering for
their meeting this evening
as jon is making his way there ghost
tries to follow him but jon grabs him by
the fur
then wrestles him back inside when jon
enters the hall
he notices the wildlings outnumber the
night's watch by about
five to one right after jon gets
everyone seated
he says i have summoned all of you here
so we can discuss the relief of heart
home
thousands of the free folk are gathered
there freezing and starving
and we even had reports of the dead
things that are in the woods
the ships i sent have mostly been
wrecked by the storm
we must send what help we can by land or
let them die
i had hoped i could lead the mission
myself and bring back as many of the
free folk that could survive the journey
but now i find i cannot go to heart home
that mission will now be led by torment
giants bane known to you all
i have sworn that i would give him as
many men as he needs
one of the men shouts at john and where
will you be
hiding a kessel black with your white
dog no
said john i ride south then jon reads
them the letter sent to him by ramsay
snow
the shield hall went mad everyone
started shouting at once
their swords were brandished axes were
smashed against shields
jon then says i will not ask the night's
watch to forswear their vows
the night's watch will make for heart
home i ride to winterfell alone
unless unless there is any man who will
come stand with me
the shield hall erupted once again men
were now standing on their feet
but jon also noticed some men of the
night's watch were slipping out of the
back door
that did not bother jon he thinks no man
can ever say i made my brothers break
their vows
if this is oath-breaking the crime is
mine and mine alone
right as john leaves the hall he hears a
shout so loud it seemed to shake the
wall
whoever it was that screamed must have
been in agony
jon starts running but by the time he
gets there the screaming has stopped
1 1 the giant was dangling a bloody body
by one leg
the dead man's sword arm was laying
several yards away
let him go shouted jon one one
let him go one one did not hear or did
not understand
the giant was bleeding himself he had
sword cuts on his belly
and on his arm then he swung the dead
knight against the gravestone wall
until the man's head was read as a
summer melon his blood and bone were
flying everywhere
a lot of the other men started coming
outside into the courtyard
form a line jon commanded jon was hoping
no one tried to avenge the knight one
one killed
the giant howled again then ripped off
the man's other arm
stay back john shouted you're scaring
him
put away your steel john wondered could
everyone else see that the giant was
already bleeding
it's not like the giant did this for no
reason jon had to find a way to settle
everyone down
or else more men would die castle black
was now
an absolute disaster all the choices
john had made are now blowing up right
in his face
john saw the glen of steel no blades he
screamed
wick put the knife away
he meant to say when wick whittlestick
slashed at his throat
the word turned into a grunt jon spun
away from the knife
just enough so it barely grazed his skin
he cut me
when he felt the side of his neck blood
well between his fingers
why john thought for the watch
wick slashed at him again this time john
caught his wrist and bent his arm back
until he dropped the dagger
the gangling steward backed away his
hands upraised as if to say
not me it was not me men were screaming
jon reached for longclaw but his fingers
had grown stiff
somehow he could not seem to get the
sword free of its scabbard
then beau and mars stood there before
him tears running down his cheeks
for the watch he punched john in the
belly and when he pulled his hand away
the dagger stayed where he had buried it
jon fell to his knees
he found the dagger's hilt and wrenched
it free in the cold night air the wound
was smoking
ghost he whispered stick them with the
pointy end he thought
when the third dagger took him between
the shoulder blades
he gave a grunt and fell face first into
the snow
he never felt the fourth knife only the
cold
[Music]
so
you